[Musik]
live aus köln
der presseclub mit volker herres
herzlich willkommen schönen sonntag aus
köln schön dass sie dabei sind der
teufel lauert hinter jeder tür hat
kardinal marx der erzbischof von münchen
und freising einst gesagt und dieser
tage spricht er viel über die dunkle
seite kirchlichen lebens denn ein vom
erzbistum münchen beauftragtes gutachten
einer münchner anwaltskanzlei zum
sexuellen missbrauch gleicht einer
bilanz des schreckens es gleicht einem
dann tischen inferno aus konzentrischen
kreisen der qual moralisch insolvent
bewegt sich die katholische kirche bei
der aufarbeitung von missbräuchen
bislang im kreislauf des scheiterns
[Musik]
wir sehen ein desaster sagt kardinal
marx eine dunkle seite der katholischen
kirche die laut münchener gutachten über
jahrzehnte zu wenig gegen missbrauch und
gewalt getan habe fast 500 opfer mehr
als 200 mutmaßliche täter eine riesige
dunkelziffer es gab bei uns
und ich bin seit 25 jahren bischof
kein wirkliches interesse an ihrem
schicksal an ihrem leiden
das hat nach meiner auffassung auch
systemische gründe und zugleich trage
ich dafür als amtierender erzbischof
moralische verantwortung
missbrauch vertuscht aufarbeitung
verschleppt zahlreiche gutachten belegen
dass neu ist jetzt der vorwurf an dem
ehemaligen papst benedikt er habe
gelogen für die gesamte katholische
kirche seien reformen unabdingbar betont
marx zu spät für viele gläubige die
reihenweise austreten es geht um die
ebene ganz spezielle aufbereitung dieser
ganzen fälle wie das alles vertuscht
wird und das kann nicht sein
es müsste alles an also eine kirche in
der krise die kommende woche beim
synodalen weg über die so notwendigen
reformen beraten will
missbraucht vertuscht gelogen das
moralische entfernung der katholischen
kirche das ist unser thema heute hier im
presseclub darüber wollen wir
diskutieren und das sind heute meine
gäste claudia keller ist
stellvertretende chefredakteurin von
chrismon einer monatlich erscheinenden
zeitschrift der evangelischen kirche in
deutschland zuvor hat sie viele jahre
für den berliner tagesspiegel über
religiöse und kirchliche fragen
berichtet andreas püttmann ist
politikwissenschaftler und journalist er
hat sich wissenschaftlich wie
publizistisch mit fragen von kirche und
politik auseinandergesetzt 2017 erschien
sein buch wie katholisch ist deutschland
und was hat es davon er berät das
zentralkomitee der deutschen katholiken
in politischen grundfragen georg löwisch
ist chefredakteur von christ und welt
den extra seiten der wochenzeitung die
zeit für glaube geist und gesellschaft
und er schreibt als autor für die zeit
und christina ziel gearbeitet als
reporterin für den wdr für ihren film
der kardinal und die missbrauchs akten
hat sie betroffene von sexualisierter
gewalt in der kirche über ein jahr lang
begleitet seien sie alle herzlich
willkommen und noch ein hinweis wie
immer streamen wir unsere sendung auch
live in den sozialen netzwerken wenn sie
also fragen oder meinungen zu unserem
heutigen thema haben stand schreiben sie
uns melden sie sich wir freuen uns auf
ihre beiträge frau züge bevor wir über
den schaden für die katholische kirche
reden lassen sie uns zunächst auf die
opfer blicken wie groß ist ihre hoffnung
dass diese menschen diese betroffenen
nach veröffentlichung dieses gutachtens
nun endlich so etwas erfahren wie
gerechtigkeit
also wenn ich mit den betroffenen reden
mit denen ich ja immer noch in kontakt
bin dann
ist da im moment noch keine hoffnungen
wenn man herrn marx hat reden hören über
dieses gutachten mann musste eine woche
darauf warten bis er sich geäußert hat
dann war ja vor allen dingen zu hören
jetzt müsste sich der eine nochmals
äußern dann müsste sich der andere
äußern also wahre konsequenzen haben wir
bisher nicht gehört und das hören
natürlich auch die betroffenen und ich
bin auch nicht sicher ob die neuen
gutachten und noch ein gutachten
brauchen wenn wir mal sehen 27 bistümer
gibt es in deutschland bisher 27
gutachten auf dem tisch haben
es erfasst ein spiel auf zeit was einige
betroffene der kirche auch vorwerfen
also ich glaube dass die hoffnungen der
betroffenen wirklich an diesen gutachten
nicht mehr hängt sondern die wollen
einfach taten sehen sie sprechen die
reaktion von kardinal marx anhält
löwisch wir haben sie auch im einspieler
noch mal gesehen er hat eingeräumt dass
die vom missbrauch betroffenen
eigentlich mehr oder weniger übersehen
wurden dass die kirche kein echtes
interesse an ihnen hatte wie ist diese
attitüde zu erkennen da zunächst mal ist
es so man muss kardinal marx ja schon
zugutehalten dass sie dieses gutachten
in auftrag gegeben hat und
veröffentlicht hat und da vielleicht
kleine einschränkung zu dem was
christina zugesagt hat dieses gutachten
stellt schon die betroffenen ja schon
ein stück auch in den mittelpunkt hat
mit ihnen gesprochen hat ein erzähl raum
geschaffen die wurden willkommen
geheißen so kann ein anderer markt muss
man sagen
dieses desaster ist auch sein desaster
das ist nicht nur das desaster der
kirche auch nach 2010 nach dem großen
knall der aufdeckung von canisius hat er
diesen knall diesen schuss nicht gehört
das gutachten belegt er hat
missbrauchsfälle zur kenntnis genommen
hat dann aber seinen ordinariat machen
lassen und hat nicht wirklich war nicht
wirklich dahinter her dass dann auch
etwas lassen sie diese gleichgültigkeit
eines hirten gegenüber den opfern von
denen er wusste dass er ist teil des
systems hat ja selber gesagt in ihrem
beitrag dass er 25 jahre schon bischof
ist und es gefällt offensichtlich schwer
sich daran ja das ist auch keine sache
wo man sich daran gewöhnen muss sondern
dass eine sache wo man erkennen muss
spätestens 2010 es ist was anderes es
ist das aller vordringlichste kinder zu
schützen und priester die beschuldigt
werden zunächst mal aus dem verkehr zu
ziehen und aus dieser macht und
vertrauensposition des seelsorgers zu
nehmen und da war er
lange lange noch halbherzig es geht um
mehr als das erzbistum münchen frank
eller
der missbrauchsskandal die wiese ist im
zentrum des vatikans angekommen denn
auch der emeritierte papst benedikt
wenn auch viel fälle vorgeworfen und vor
allen dingen er soll gegenüber den
gutachtern die unwahrheit gesagt haben
was ist da passiert ja also das ist
jetzt das neue die gutachter
bescheinigen er dem der kirche dass sie
was paranoia haft versucht das den ruf
der kirche die institution zu schützen
den ruf zu schützen und jetzt weiß man
eben dass diese paranoia bis ganz oben
hinauf rannte und ja ratzinger ich weiß
nicht ob er das selber geschrieben hat
ob es anwälte geschrieben haben
verteidigt sich verteidigt jeden
einzelnen schritt er habe nichts gewusst
er konnte nichts wissen selbst wenn er
ein wenn wenn auf einem dokument steht
der erzbischof habe es zur kenntnis
bekommen argumentiert er heißt das ja
noch lange nicht dass er das auch
gelesen habe also es ist ich finde das
sehr bedrückend das zu lesen also kein
einziges mal ja es tut mir leid ich habe
da fehler begangen ich habe nicht
hingeschaut ich war mit anderen dingen
beschäftigt es im klein-klein ich wusste
nichts ich konnte nichts wissen das ist
wahrlich also ich bin unschuldigen das
vielleicht mal zu ergänzen die
verteidigung ist fast ebenso skandalös
wie die vertuschung und diese
verteidigung die relativierung und das
ständige argumentieren mit dem zeitgeist
sexueller missbrauch war immer strafbar
in deutschland diese relativierung die
findet ja nicht im jahr 1980 statt die
findet nicht im jahr 2010 statt sondern
20 21 und der papst hat das
unterschrieben mit seinem namen da steht
benedikt runter ist das so erdmann wird
in sachen missbrauch mehr vertuscht und
verwaltet und weniger bekämpft und
aufgeklärt hat benedikt die unwahrheit
gesagt also offensichtlich ist
jahrzehntelang vertuscht worden und bei
benedikt ist es schon erschreckend dass
er sich also in kleinteilige
selbstrechtfertigung
erklärungen 82 seiten flüchtet also mit
so am boden also mit verstörenden
aussagen wie dass dieser oder jener
priester eben privat in dem moment
gehandelt habe und nicht eine klausel
ist ein oder das einer also masturbiert
habe vor mädchen und sie ja nicht
berührt habe
das mag ja kirchenrechtlich
irgendwelche anhaltspunkte haben aber
das ist ja nicht das worum es eigentlich
geht und man wünschte sich eigentlich
dass er sagt es tut mir schrecklich leid
ich bin nachlässig gewesen in meiner
sorgfaltspflicht als bischof ich habe
mich nicht erkundigt was ist mit dem
priester der mir von essen hier
überstellt wird nach münchen und völlig
unabhängig von der frage ob denn nun in
dieser sitzung gewesen ist der
erzbischof
muss er doch wenn ein bischof wegen
psychotherapie und obdach in einer
wohnung im erzbistum münchen überstellt
wird muss er sich doch erkundigen was
ist denn da los und dann schlüsse daraus
ziehen und dafür sorgen dass er nicht in
die paar seelsorge kommt also hier fehlt
mir also wirklich sehr im unterschied zu
kardinal marx muss ich sagen bei dem ich
den eindruck habe dass er authentisch
betroffen ist und dass er durch diesen
schrecklichen satz
die kinder haben uns nicht wesentlich
interessiert sicher im grunde auch
selbst eigentlich zum rückzug
vorschlägt denn die dna des christentums
ist empathie und jesus hat speziell über
die kinder gesprochen dass diejenigen
die den übles antun und sie verführen
das denen ein mühlstein um den hals
gehängt wird und sie auf die tiefen des
meeres versenkt werden müssen und dann
kann man eigentlich als köstlicher
bischof nicht sagen die kinder haben uns
nicht interessiert also das war
vielleicht der erschütterndste satz aber
dann gäbe es mal hat man in die runde
weil sie es ansprechen muss nach diesem
gutachten muss es auch personelle
konsequenzen an der spitze der
katholischen kirche geben
selbstverständlich zweimal wird genügt
also bitte naja also was weiß ich eben
nachgedacht habe wir haben darüber
gesprochen dass der ehemalige papst 80
seiten schreibt und dann geht herr marx
hin und äußert sich in dieser
pressekonferenz nicht zu zum ehemaligen
papst benedikt sondern er schweigt das
im grunde tut und sagt dann na ja er
könne sich ja jetzt noch mal äußern und
da finde ich es wird halt nicht mehr
glaubwürdig wenn man sagt und jetzt hat
man sich nochmal erklären und nochmal
erklären und auf der anderen seite hat
man betroffene die seit jahren versuchen
sich zu erklären und den wird immer
gesagt ja jetzt haben wir euch zugehört
wir haben es verstanden was ihr möchtet
und dann tut man genau das gegenteil
oder man tut zumindest andere dinge also
dass die chance für immer und immer
wieder erklärungen ist einfach für
kleriker immer noch sehr viel größer als
für die menschen über die wir eigentlich
reden nämlich den so schreckliches leid
angetan wurde sehen sie denn her
libyschen ernsthaftes bemühen jetzt nach
vorstellung dieses gutachtens der kirche
um erneuerung um aufklärung die kirche
ist jetzt bis hierher gekommen aber sie
kommt offensichtlich nicht weiter das
hat ja vorzüge schon geschildert marx
hat
1900 seiten gutachten vorlegen das die
stellungnahmen der kleriker die dort
belastet werden enthält und er sagt er
relativiert das eigene gutachten und
sagt das ist jetzt ein wichtiger
baustein ja was will er dennoch und
damit sagt er eigentlich selber jetzt
sollte mal eine andere instanz kommen
und diese andere instanz heißt nach
meinem dafürhalten start ich würde noch
was ich würde sagen wenn er nicht wenn
er nicht zurücktritt dann würde ich von
ihm erwarten dass er sich klar
distanziert von ratzinger von dem er
seine ganze karriere lang gefördert
wurde also sein ganzer weg ist von
ratzinger abhängig gewesen dass er sich
von diesem vater auch distanziert und
dass er jetzt er sagt ja er klebt nicht
an seinem posten er könnte ja auch diese
freiheit die daraus entsteht nutzen und
zu sagen jetzt treibe ich mal wirklich
reform hier in meinem bistum voran wie
er sie ja auf dem synodalen weg
angeblich auch für gut heißt ja er
könnte frauen im dom predigen lassen
jeden sonntag er könnte sich wirklich in
die missbrauchsthematik
einarbeiten sich kompetenz aneignen sich
wirklich um die betroffenen kümmern so
insofern die das wollen sich auch
persönlich mit ihnen treffen und sich
darauf wirklich einlassen apple
mannschaft die katholische kirche dass
diese beschriebene erneuerung mit dem
bestehenden spitzenpersonal sag ich mal
etwas salopp oder muss es dort auch
personelle wechsel geben das gutachten
hebt er hervor dass seit 2010 ist
entschlossene bemühungen gab den umgang
mit den missbrauchsfällen
entscheidend zu verbessern
und neue vorwürfe sind auch in den
letzten zehn jahren deutlich
zurückgegangen
insofern gibt es also lob zum beispiel
für die präventionsarbeit ausdrücklich
es gab ja schon 2010 das gutachten und
das ist nicht weniger erschreckend zu
lesen da geht es also mehr um die
strukturen also etwa die aktenführung
wie also offensichtlich auch akten
gefleddert wurden bereinigt wurden also
das einfach auch chaos herrscht und man
hat offensichtlich in münchen durchaus
neben manchem was noch
verbesserungswürdig ist was dann
aufgelistet wird auch durchaus sich das
schon zu herzen genommen insofern gibt
kann man nicht sagen es geschieht
einfach gar nichts und es werden keine
schlüsse gezogen es hat sich nichts
verbessert doch nach aussagen der
gutachter hat sich etwas verbessert die
frage jetzt für die personalien
also köpfe rollen zu lassen ist
natürlich das was unsere emotionen
entspricht die frage ist ob das was
danach kommt nach wegen um die symbolik
von köpfe ja es geht ja darum ob die
handelnden personen ja gezeigt haben
dass sie die kraft zur aufklärung und
zur erneuerung genommen also bei
kardinal marx um das jetzt konkret zu
machen glaube ich schon zumal man ja
auch nicht weiß was in trier noch aus
seiner zeit als bischof ans tageslicht
kommt und weil er nun seit zwölf jahren
auch ein gesicht dieser stockenden
aufklärung ist weil zb in seinem
erzbistum
präventionsbeauftragte erst im oktober
zweieinhalb jahre später nach dem ersten
missbrauchsskandal im januar 2010 im
oktober
2002 oder drei
präventionsbeauftragter eingeführt
wurden also wegen der langsamkeit auch
des prozesses den das gutachten
kritisiert meine ich gibt es gute gründe
für einen rücktritt freilich muss man
sagen im unterschied zu anderen
bistümern und bischöfen wo noch gar
keine gutachten vorliegen wo man auch
überhaupt nichts hört wo es verdächtig
still ist kann man sagen dass kardinal
marx sich doch auch als jemand zeigt der
lernbereit ist und der glaube ich schon
die stunde verstanden hat er hat ja
gesagt also das ist ein nicht nur einen
tiefpunkt sondern ein toter punkt
unserer kirche und ich wünschte mir
diese einsicht auch bei manchem anderen
insofern kann ich mir auch vorstellen
dass er eine konstruktive rolle auch in
zukunft spielen kann halten würde sagen
es nicht zurücktreten ja aber herrscht
in einem gutachten ist auch die rede
davon dass es eng geknüpften netzwerke
gibt und wechselseitige
erpressungspotenzial innerhalb der
katholischen kirche also ein kartell des
schweigens auch haben sie das zutrauen
dass die katholische kirche diese krise
in sachen missbrauch aus eigener kraft
aus sich selbst heraus bewältigen kann
ich würde schon noch weiter gehen also
es ist schon so es gibt und bei den
bischöfen welche die sind mehr
verstrickt und weniger verstrickt in
vertuschungen es gibt welche die haben
eben später angefangen nach 2010 und
sind deswegen von anfang an entschlossen
vorgegangen aber ich würde trotzdem
sagen wenn niemand aufhört kann auch
keiner anfangen und ich verweise da gern
auf chile in chile hat 2018 die gesamte
chilenische bischofskonferenz also alle
bischöfe dem papst den rücktritt
angeboten ange rücktritte hat er sofort
akzeptiert andere nach überprüfung und
mancher der im amt belassen warum nicht
mal diesen schritt das ist ja hätte man
das ist ja wieder so eine system denkt
zu sagen ja wenn der markt weg ist wer
übernimmt sind dann wir haben keinen
anderen und so weiter die herren haben
jetzt wirklich lange wirklich lange die
chance gehabt wir haben nicht zehn jahre
nach canisius wie immer wieder gesagt
wird sondern zwölf jahre und die demut
die sie permanent neu inszenieren wenn
solche gutachten vorgestellt werden das
sind ja meine kollegin christiane florin
hat mal formuliert demuths giganten ja
es sind demos giganten aber zu diesem
demut die gant ismus kann doch auch
gehören dass man einfach mal vater wird
die haben doch alle im beruf gelernt
warum werden wir nicht pfarrer oder dem
ins kloster oder machen was ganz anderes
warum müssen die bischöfe bleiben ja die
antwort ist es ist so banal es ist fast
klischeehaft sie haben nichts anderes
sie kennen nichts anderes wenn sie die
gutachten lesen und die dokumente dass
wir viel getan haben in den letzten
anderthalb jahren eine sache da stoßen
sie immer wieder drauf es geht dauernd
um karrieren karrieren von missbrauchs
priestern karrieren von vorgesetzten
karrieren von bischöfen das ist wirklich
kalt alan und bezweifeln die kraft der
erneuerung aus sich selbst heraus
wo kommt denn eigentlich vor in der
wirtschaft über in der politik dass
jemand so lange rum macht und das ende
ist nur der 75 geburtstag frau lyla da
muss ich sie mal fragen christa und sie
arbeiten für chrismon auch die
evangelische kirche kämpft mit dem thema
missbrauch das ist heute nicht im
zentrum unseres presseclubs aber auch
ein großes thema ja wo sind denn
systemische unterschiede warum tut sich
die katholische kirche möglicherweise
auf andere weise schwer mit dem thema
ich will nicht sagen dass sich die
evangelische kirche damit nicht leicht
die evangelische kirche ringt auch und
chrismon hatte auch immer wieder
überfälle geschrieben die verschleppt
wurden vertuscht wurden
tatsächlich sind die faktoren die
missbrauch begünstigen in der
evangelischen kirche ein bisschen anders
gelagert da hat man sich ja immer
überhoben ja die katholische kirche mit
ihrer verklemmte sexualmoral
wir sind die tollen wir sind die
liberalen und das war dann genau das
einfallstor für den missbrauch das eben
die coolen pfarrer mit den konfirmanden
beim zelten ja komm doch in mein zelt
und stell dich nicht so an und sei nicht
so prüde und
also da sind auch die die betroffenen
eher mädchen und er
älter als die in keiner achtjährigen
jungs
viele mädchen in der katholischen kirche
die missbraucht worden sind ich glaube
da gibt es schon ein bisschen aber sie
sehen systemischen unterschied da gibt's
schon systemischen unterschied
da sind möglicherweise auch nicht nur
die pfarrer die betreuer die die täter
sondern auch jugendleiter noch mehr als
in der katholischen kirche aber
letztlich wie groß das ausmaß ist weiß
man alles auch noch nicht weil so eine
umfassende studie ist erst vor einem
guten jahr in auftrag gegeben worden da
kommt auch frühestens nächstes jahr ein
ergebnis
und ja die evangelische kirche hat auch
einiges auf den weg gebracht und es
trotzdem auch immer wieder am anfang und
findet keinen angemessenen umgang mit
den betroffenen und die wahrnehmungen
gehen wahnsinnig auseinander die
bischöfe sagen wir tun soviel und die
betroffenen haben nach wie vor das
gefühl wir werden nicht wahrgenommen wir
stehen eben auch bei euch nicht im
mittelpunkt und ich finde auch bei der
evangelischen kirche merkt man den
schritt von der basis in die hierarchie
also ich hab mir gerade einen fall wo
eine gemeinde vor ort aus gerüchten
aufklären möchte und immer wieder
richtung landeskirche sagt könnt ihr uns
bitte helfen und die kriegen einfach
nicht das feedback die kriegen nicht die
hilfe die sie brauchen und da merkt man
es wird auch da in der hierarchie
verschleppt ähnlich wie es eben in der
katholischen kirche auch war wobei man
glaube ich in der katholischen kirche
auch sagen muss es gibt auch das dorf
die den betroffenen allein gelassen
haben obwohl es vielleicht viele bewusst
haben weil es vielleicht auch dieses
überhöhtes priesterbild gibt und der
priester ebenso heilig ist und eben
vielen kindern auch gar nicht geglaubt
wurden also am anfang meiner recherche
habe ich gelernt ein kind braucht sieben
erwachsene bevor ihm einer glaubt also
welche achtjährige kleine junge hat
überhaupt sieben erwachsene die ihr
ansprechen kann und das ist glaube ich
auch was wo auch die katholiken an der
basis besser hätten seien heute aber
nach wollte ich noch mal kurz hinweis
des forschungs problem ist nicht nur
eines der hierarchie was von oben nach
unten kommt sondern es kommt auch von
unten also es gibt eben die fans eines
bestimmten pfarrers die nach dem motto
was nicht sein darf das nicht sein kann
dann ihren star verteidigen und es gibt
natürlich also die betonfraktion die
sowieso möchte dass sich nichts ändert
und also bereit ist alles zu verteidigen
also right or wrong my country politisch
gesprochen
und das ist auch eine nicht zu
vernachlässigende gruppe ist zwar eine
minderheit aber nach empirischen
erhebung kann man so von 10 bis 15
prozent auch im katholizismus ausgehen
der kompromisslos beharrenden wo man
also auch das problem an der basis hat
und das meinte ich übrigens also mit den
mit dem köpfe rollen also bei marx würde
ich sagen sollte vielleicht auch
zurücktreten ich würde es an seiner
stelle aber ich warne davor zu meinen
wenn wir sozusagen jetzt also die spitze
ausgewechselt haben dann sind wir ein
erhebliches stück weiter
sondern die probleme sind strukturell
und sie sind auch zum teil kirchen
ideologisch und davon sind alle
betroffen ich will noch mal im moment
bei den opfern und betroffenen bleiben
sie haben es auch gerade angesprochen
ist können uns ja welche zuschauen
zuhören zurzeit
die diskussion dreht sich sehr schnell
um den schaden für die katholische
kirche aber haben sie den eindruck nach
diesem gutachten das jetzt den opfern
den betroffenen so etwas wie
wiedergutmachung kann man es überhaupt
wieder gutmachen aber gerechtigkeit
widerfährt dass sich da tatsächlich
etwas ändert oder muss man den
eigentlich sagen schön dass er darüber
diskutiert aber die betroffenen stehen
gleich im mittelpunkt also ich finde
flying darstellt dass der schutz der
kinder immer noch nicht im mittelpunkt
steht heute noch nicht weggucken so viel
in die vergangenheit wir lesen 1900
seiten über die vergangenheit ich kann
vielleicht kurz von der recherche
vergangene woche erzählen wir haben in
köln ja gerade einen priester der
ausnahmsweise vor gericht steht fahrer
eben vor dem weltlichen gericht
vielleicht jetzt mal erzählt bekommt
die man sich an regeln hält und ich habe
mehr aus einer routine heraus das
erzbistum köln gefragt wie gehen sie
eigentlich im moment mit den tätern um
die hier leben wo leben die müssen dem
klosterleben die werden die kontrolliert
und hab mir schreiben mir irgendwas
bewährungshelfer die schreiben dafür
haben wir jetzt eine kommission
gegründet die antwort ist im grunde also
auch nach 2018 nach der großen studie
für ganz deutschland nach dem gutachten
vom bistum köln der der schutz der
kinder ist immer noch nicht so präsent
dass man jetzt jemanden hat ja damals
klingelt und guckt wie solche leute
eigentlich leben sich guck mal
stehen die schon im mittelpunkt also
nein stehen sie noch nicht es geht ja
auch darum jetzt um aufarbeitung
kommission die jedes bistum gründen soll
und wenn ich da so rein gucken da sind
dann von in so einer kommission sieben
leute und auch nur zwei betroffene die
dann
kirchenvertretern experten gegenüber
sitzen also das ist auch noch nicht wir
stehen im mittelpunkt ich hatte gerade
mal ins ins netz weil wir ja auch unser
publikum gern beteiligen in unseren
diskussionen und dort schreibt irmgard
katzorke auf twitter aber wer hilft
eigentlich den opfern der staat ist in
der pflicht und muss den opfern eine
stimme geben wie sieht es da aus das
kann ich auch würde ich auch gerne was
dazu sagen also
das ist richtig der staat steht in der
pflicht und da sehe ich den staat aber
jetzt auch nicht so dass er in den
letzten zehn jahren für dieses thema
gebrannt hätte also die samba die die
politik ja also es gibt einen
missbrauchsbeauftragten der
bundesregierung
und eine unabhängige aufarbeitung
kommission die
er ins leben gerufen hat es gibt einen
nationalen rat gegen
missbrauch aber das hängt alles so in
der luft das ist per kabinettsbeschluss
das ist per bundestagsbeschluss das wird
seit langem von dem
missbrauchsbeauftragten herrn röhrig
gefordert dass es da eine gesetzliche
grundlage gibt andere länder australien
haben eine kommission die institution
übergreifend das thema über viele jahre
richtig aufgearbeitet hat also auch dem
sport auf die schulen die haben sich das
richtig zu eigen gemacht die die politik
und das sehe ich hier nicht so da muss
man ja auch sagen welche kompetenzen
haben die in berlin denn welche
kompetenzen hat herr röhrig der war bis
vor kurzem dem parlament nicht mal zum
bericht verpflichtet und hat auch in
interviews immer wieder gesagt dass er
auch nicht das gefühl dass ihn niemand
will weil das ja immer so eklig ist
niemand will mit so einem thema in den
wahlkampf ziehen und sich damit
identifizieren lassen und die kommission
die es in deutschland gibt die dürfen
keine akten angucken die können nicht in
staatliche archive gucken es ist ein das
sind eher harmlose die wada am bayern
und die betroffenen selber müssen dann
die arbeit machen und die gefahr ist
immer noch dass sie wieder
retraumatisierung werden weil dann würde
ich ja noch mal gut man bei der rolle
der justiz auch bleiben weil das im netz
ich sehe dass gerade parallel beobachtet
das was unsere zuhörer zuschauer dort an
reaktionen liefern ein thema ist
kirchenrecht und der versuch der
katholischen kirche straftatbestände
selbst und ohne den staat aufklären zu
wollen da ist die rede von geheimer
parallel justiz ist dies alles noch
zeitgemäß oder muss ich das nicht ändern
und der staat auf dem gebiet des
missbrauchs bei der kirche genauso tätig
sein wie auf anderen feldern auch das
ist nicht nur nicht zeitgemäß sondern
auch verboten also der staaten muss
seinen rechtsanspruch überall
durchsetzen es gibt keine rechtsfreien
räume auch keine religiös begründeten
und das kirchenrecht ist ja auch nicht
gedacht als alternativ recht zum
weltlichen recht sondern sozusagen als
verdoppelung also es müssten dann
prozesse geführt werden wo
straffälligkeit vorliegt sowohl von
weltlichen instanzen als auch zusätzlich
vom kirchlichen instanzen weil es sich
ja dann auch spezielle geistliche
strafen gibt also das darf sich
sozusagen nicht als alternative
gegenüber stehen sondern es muss
sozusagen doppelt
verfolgt werden was die
wahrheitskommission in irland und
australien angeht
ja das kann man machen und ich sag mal
aus kirchlicher sicht und einige
bischöfe haben sich ja auch so geäußert
wäre es wahrscheinlich auch besser
gewesen von vornherein zu sagen wir
lassen es ganz unabhängig aufarbeiten es
gab allerdings auch dort in australien
und irland verwerfungen mit rücktritten
von vorsitzenden mit klagen dass die
politik doch nicht genug unterstützung
gibt mit betroffenen die sich zu einem
drittel dann wieder zurückgezogen haben
und doch nicht ausgesagt haben also
einfach wird es dadurch auch nicht wenn
der staat sich der sache annimmt und
ganz wichtig ist natürlich auch dass man
nicht den eindruck haben darf hier wird
jetzt eine institution in der es
missbrauch gab einer sonder behandlung
zugeführt und in die anderen ecken
schauen wir nicht hinein also das muss
dann tatsächlich über geradezu würde ich
gern einen eintrag in unserem gästebuch
in die runde geben armin holle schreibt
warum sind die eltern der missbrauchten
kinder nicht zur polizei gegangen hätte
man dann nicht hätte dann nicht die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt hätte dann
nicht eingerichteten täter verurteilen
und über sie ein berufsverbot verhängen
können was sagen sie herr rolle
die kinder haben sich ja oft gar nicht
getraut das den eltern zu sagen oder die
eltern haben auch den kindern nicht
geglaubt weil auch für die eltern war
das unvorstellbar dass ein der tolle
priester der tolle pfarrer sowas tut
also viele kinder fühlten sich da ja
auch sehr allein gelassen
darf ich noch mal was zu den betroffenen
sagen
oder die betroffenen in kombination mit
dem staat damit kann der staat anfangen
da gibt es nämlich eine idee die gibt es
auch in der spd-fraktion die betroffenen
zu unterstützen und zu ermächtigen wenn
die betroffenen jetzt an der aufklärung
beteiligt werden dann findet das in
aller regel unter dem dach der kirche
statt in betroffenen bei regen die
natürliche finanziert wo sich die
betroffenen bei
generalvikariat und ordinariate bewerben
müssen die betroffenen müssen sich
selbst ermächtigen können reicht das
nein aber es ist ein sehr wichtiger
baustein weil sie haben
sie haben es erlebt und sie sollten
beteiligt werden an dieser aufarbeitung
und sie üben auch den nötigen druck aus
nur sie müssen ermächtigt werden und das
ist mal ein vorschlag aus der politik
den ich gut finde und zwar nicht nur auf
der fachpolitiker ebene sondern auch das
stimmt politiker ermächtigt
es muss einfach einen betroffenen
verband geben der
einfach in die fähigkeit versetzt werden
sich dann auch mit den mit den mächtigen
der kirche auseinander zu setzen das
finde ich eine super idee aber auch die
wünsche zu hören es gibt zb im märz wird
in köln das erste bundesweit erste
betroffenen café die betroffenen
beratungsstelle gegründet die nicht von
der kirche finanziert wird da gibt es
einen verein die leute überreden die aus
der kirche austreten doch die
kirchengelder stadt ist die
kirchensteuer stattdessen zu spenden und
von diesem geld wird es dieses beratungs
café geben das ist was was betroffene
mir seit jahren erzählen wir wollen in
einen raum kommen und wir eben nicht im
generalvikar antwort stehen müssen
sollen wir wollen mal innenraum kommen
wo andere sind die unsere geschichte
kennen wo wir uns nicht erklären müssen
und wo leute und so beraten wie wir uns
das wünschen das sagen die seit jahren
aber niemand reagiert darauf und jetzt
organisieren sie ist mehr oder weniger
selber aber da könnte natürlich eine
regierung hingehen und sagen da ist eine
super idee das machen wir jetzt an jedem
bundesland dann will ich das thema noch
mal öffnen und in die runde geben
derzeit erleben wir eine reihe einen von
austritten aus der kirche in bayern sind
standesämter überfordert kommen gar
nicht nach weil die gläubigen der
katholischen kirche offenbar
davonrennen kardinal marx hat in der
pressekonferenz zum gutachten gesagt ich
zitiere das mal es gebe keine zukunft
des christentums in unserem lande ohne
eine
grundsätzlich erneuerte kirche ist der
niedergang der katholischen kirche noch
aufzuhalten oder hat sie die kraft
wirklich zu einer umfassenden erneuerung
ich war das schweigen in der runde oder
das also sommerleseclub darf man eine
sekunde nachdenken bevor man spricht das
ist in ordnung aber es sagt ja auch was
aus dass bei so einer grundsätzlichen
frage sie alle ins grübeln da wie man
mit einer provokanten these hervortreten
erstaunlich ist eigentlich schon seit
langen jahren nicht wie viele leute
jedes jahr aus der kirche austreten
sondern wie weniger austreten denn wenn
man sich genau anschaut was die menschen
in deutschland glauben was auch die
kirchenmitglieder glauben etwa im moment
37 prozent die an jesus christus als
sohn gottes glauben in deutschland bei
50% mitgliedschaft in den christlichen
kirchen oder 24 prozent der deutschen an
die auferstehung oder wenn man sich
anschaut wie in den religionsmonitor
studien das verhältnis zur eigenen
kirche beschrieben wird und zum glauben
dann sagen 17 prozent der deutschen
katholiken
dass sie weder gläubige christen sind
noch ihrer kirche verbunden
da fragt man sich doch warum sind jedes
jahr immer nur ein prozent ausgetreten
das heißt die skandale haben die krise
verschärft aber es gibt tiefere ursachen
gesellschaftlicher art weltanschauliche
art zivilisatorischer art die schon vor
zehn zwanzig jahren also vor der
piusbrüder der missbrauchs der limburger
krise
haben ahnen lassen dass sich deutschland
wie große teile auch der westlichen welt
und christlichen werten kardinal marx
hat in seiner pressekonferenz um
gutachten betont es gebe nur eine
erneuerung auf synodalen wege
nächste woche tagen die beschriftet zum
thema synodaler weg wie
erfolgversprechend ist es ich weiß es
auch wieder einen ich wollte noch mal
kurz das sich und seine löwen schaffen
sie die erneuerung es bleibt keine
alternative sie müssen sich erneut
trotzdem leute scharenweise auch weiter
austreten weil diese erneuerung wird ja
wird wird lange dauern es wird stück für
stück gehen und das ist den ist in
katholikinnen und katholiken zu lang sie
werden trotzdem weiter austreten sie
werden schrumpfen ok also dann synodaler
weg ist das ein weg der erneuerung für
die katholische kirche also dieser
begriff vielleicht muss man das erstmal
erklären
der begriff ist ja schon so kompliziert
und eigentlich so unbekannt also da geht
es darum dass 200 leute die hälfte sind
erika auch alle bischöfe und die hälfte
sind laien sich zusammentun und
reformvorhaben gesprächen über die rolle
der frau in der katholischen kirche über
das priesterbild über die
machtstrukturen und über die sexualmoral
das sind die vier themen die wollten
eigentlich schon fertig sein witzig bei
wikipedia steht noch das nächste woche
die abschließende veranstaltung sein
sollte müsste man mal erneuern jetzt
geht es nämlich dass 20 23 man sieht
daran es ist wirklich c also
insbesondere die bischöfe sind
die sind einfach eine schnecke im
weinberg des herrn ist da eine schnecke
unterwegs die ist zu langsam die sind zu
langsam und man muss auch sagen die
laien sind nicht besonders destruktiv
also wer bremst eigentlich
oben bremst immer wieder die bischöfe
bremsen und man müsste von den laien aus
die bischöfe unter in einen stärkeren
druck setzen und die bischöfe müssten
rom stärker unter druck setzen das
machen sie aber nicht ist es alles sehr
brav also
stillstand in der kirche ist auch immer
also bei denen bei dem bei dem
projekt letzte woche weil die rede von
kirche der an und ich finde sie sprechen
die 125 beschäftigten an die er sich
geoutet haben und bei den organisierten
laien ist es eher kirche der braafheid
und bei den bischöfen ist es eher kirche
der freiheit erdmann hat die katholische
kirche eine chance auf ernsthafter
erneuerung ohne ihre sexualmoral ohne
themen wie den zölibat zu verändern
genau an dem punkt wollte ich die
bischöfe gegen ein löwe in schutz nehmen
also sie sehen langsam gehen jetzt sehr
begrenzt sei habe es geht um druck auf
rom sondern man muss sich einmal die
weltkirche anschauen was wird denn in
all den fragen des synodalen weges also
zum zu den diensten kirchlichen diensten
der frauen zur sexualität zur
homosexualität et cetera in afrika in
osteuropa in nordamerika von den
gläubigen geglaubt also selbst der papst
ist ja kein alleinherrscher der jetzt
einfach mal ohne rücksicht auf die
stimmung
unter den kardinälen und bischöfen sagen
kann mit einem federstrich jetzt mache
ich jemand etwas anders und bei dem
thema was wir jetzt gerade noch
angesprochen haben also wie gott uns
schuf dieser aktion ist es ja nicht so
dass gegen kirchlichen normen verstoßen
wurde wie beim missbrauch sondern es ist
noch viel
dramatischer die norm selbst verletzt
kann es frauke eine erneuerung geben der
deutschen katholischen kirche ohne die
weltkirche ohne dass der vatikan auch
seine vorstellungen verändert ein user
auf twitter schreibt hat die kirche
überhaupt noch eine chance sich aus den
alten gewohnheiten die er aus dem
vatikan aufgegeben werden herauszufinden
also ich kenn das ist die große lähmung
über allem wann immer wir in deutschland
das gefühl haben jetzt bewegt sich war
es jetzt tut sich was jetzt will ein
bischof zurücktreten
sollte dann total überrascht weil auch
glaube ich viele katholiken an der basis
kennen das ja dass man sagt ja ich liebe
meine kirche vor ort da ist alles toll
was der papst in rom macht ist doch egal
und jetzt wird dieser papst in rom total
relevant weil die kirche in deutschland
will sich bewegen und dann blicken alle
wieder zum papst und er sagt nein der
darf nicht zurücktreten nein frauen
dürfen keine priester werden egal was
ihr euch in deutschland überlegt und
dann
muss man vielleicht irgendwann sagen
okay wenn die weltkirche so wichtig ist
ist deutschland offensichtlich so
unwichtig dann machen wir den laden hier
dicht und lassen andere länder
katholiken hier sind doch einfach machen
also was hätte denn der stefan hesse ist
pfarrer der bloß die modewelt geräte
einfach der hätte einfach wieder pfarrer
sein können oder im pfarrgarten irgend
etwas nützliches machen was hätte denn
der franziskus gemacht die
schweizergarde nach hamburg schicken
sicher nicht einfach machen sonst ich
habe vorhin schon mal gesagt der markt
könnte hier als auch mal dinge einfach
ausprobieren weil was wird das stecken
sie sagt immer heimlich außer dass er
abberufen wird und wenn er nicht am
posten klebt ist das ja kann das ja für
ihn also sicher sein
die verstecken sich hinter diesem
gehorsam aber meine erfahrung in
zahlreichen gesprächen ist jetzt auch
die können das gar nicht mehr denken
also ich hab mit einem hohen kleriker
gesprochen und habe als diese diskussion
um heese warum geht er denn nicht
einfach wenn er sieht dass der laden in
hamburg funktioniert und ich warum geht
er nicht und wir haben eine
viertelstunde darüber geredet und
gemerkt geht denken nicht gleich also
dieses dass ich sagt er dann soll er
doch gehen was in geologisch auch sagen
das können sie gar nicht denkt man sie
so darauf gedreht sind gehorsam und da
muss man sagen dann sind sie halt
gehorsam dann verlieren sie aber die
leute für diese eigentlich arbeit das
emiratische entfernen oder katholischen
kirche so lautet der titel der bittmann
der heutigen sendung welche zukunft hat
die katholische kirche abschließende
frage geht die selbstzerstörung weiter
oder schafft sie die erneuerung also es
gibt jahr für jahr mehr katholiken auf
der welt übrigens auch mehr priester es
gibt eine region die sich unterscheidet
nämlich europa und das zauberwort ist
insofern auch nicht nur gehorsam sondern
einheit und es gibt in so einem
kosmos wie der katholischen kirche eine
kulturelle ungleichzeitigkeit wo man
also kaum die unterschiedlichen
auffassungen
auch zusammenbringen kann schon in der
europäischen union sehen wir ja zwischen
west war also sie sagen es geht keinen
deutschen sonderweg sondern es ist nein
die weltkirche die volle erneuerung
stehst es geht nur es gibt es nur durch
abspaltung möglichkeit liebe kolleginnen
liebe kollegen wir sind schon am ende
der sendung an komm ich danke für die
lebhafte diskussion das war der
presseclub im ersten jahr geht's weiter
mit dem europamagazin und den presseclub
nachgefragt den gibt es jetzt wie immer
auf phoenix wir danken für ihr interesse
und wir alle hier wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen sonntag waren sie es gut
und schuss
ich begrüße sie zum presseclub
nachgefragt hier auf phoenix und dem
radio auf wdf missbraucht vertuscht
gelogen das moralische entfernen oder
katholischen kirche das ist das thema
unserer runde hier im presseclub und
jetzt sind sie dran mit ihren fragen an
meine gäste und wir gehen nach bad
rothenfelde
dort ist andrea fischer am telefon frau
fischer
studio
ich habe eine provokante ich glaube da
hatte ich hier einen falschen eintrag
das klingt nicht nach
andreas andrea okay dann ist
alles klar andrea dann herzlich
willkommen in unserer sendung und die
anmerkung bitte die anmerkung ja ich bin
ja schon gesagt ich möchte ein bisschen
provozieren
wenn man jetzt nicht wüsste dass es um
die katholische kirche geht dann könnte
man den eindruck bekommen dass es sich
hier um eine kriminelle vereinigung
handelt
ähnlich wie zb das verhalten es ja
ähnlich wie bei der sogenannten klaren
kriminalität es wird vertuscht es werden
verschiedene
zirkel aufgebaut innerhalb einer
bestimmten gruppe es gibt auch
teilnehmer der dieser kleinkriminalität
die nicht kriminell sind die aber davon
wissen dass einige teile kriminell sind
und ich muss sagen es
stört mich so ein bisschen mit
welcher chuzpe da die katholische kirche
tatsächlich vorgeht und mit welcher
nachlässigkeit auch die staatlichen
institute das ganze begleiten jetzt ganz
herzlichen dank für die frage ich gebe
das in die runde wer möchte logisch also
sie haben ich finde sie haben recht was
wir jetzt gesehen haben was enthüllt
worden ist denn die münchner gutachten
trägt mafiöse züge die leute die
kleriker wurden wurden teils zum
schweigen verdonnert auch der wichtigste
mitarbeiter von ratzinger von joseph
ratzinger dessen generalvikar wurde 2010
benötigt alle schuld auf sich zu nehmen
er hat jetzt seine meinung geändert und
gegenüber den gutachtern aufgesagt
ausgesagt das ist sozusagen
mafia mäßig das gesetz des schweigens
die omerta gegenüber außenstehenden darf
niemand belastet werden das haben wir
aber man muss natürlich auch
relativieren bei den mafia vergleichen
mafia da geht es um morde und das ist
jetzt hier nicht der fall aber mafiöse
züge würde ich schon sagen warum greift
der staat nicht ein tja weil damals sehr
erfolgreich vertuscht worden ist und ich
hoffe jetzt schon als ich würde schon
sagen da will ich auch ein putzmann
recht geben was heute abgeht in der
katholischen kirche ist nicht das was in
den 80er oder 90er jahren ab ging also
ich glaube schon wenn man hat er gelernt
und man versucht sich wenigstens nach
kräften
an das eigene recht aufzuhalten und auch
an das staatliche recht wir gehen nach
zwiesel dort ist annemarie wetzel am
telefon
hallo
danke david ich wollte gerne kein
statement abgeben ich denke an die
glaubwürdigkeit der kirche und ich denke
sie kann die glaubwürdigkeit eigentlich
nur herstellen in dem fall gegangen
gutachten nicht von der kirche sondern
von der weltlichen justiz aufgearbeitet
werden auch in verbindung mit den dafür
notwendigen
gefängnisstrafen wie auch immer und dann
wären noch mein wunsch dass der frühere
papst also der papst im ruhestand
endlich mal seine weiße kutte erste
und ganz normal in ein kloster geht wo
man ihn nicht mehr haben
die berechtigung in meinen augen so
engagiert ist ich finde die katholische
kirche beziehungsweise alle dürfen auch
evangelische mal wieder ein bisschen
glaubwürdigkeit sicher arbeiten vielen
dank frau witze für dieses statement und
wer möchte es kommentieren
also mit dem letzten anzufangen ich bin
sowieso der meinung dass das versprechen
sich in ein stilles leben des gebets
zurückzuziehen von benedikt gebrochen
wurde durch interviews durch
veröffentlichungen die zum teil sogar
intentionen des papstes konterkarierten
da wäre es in der tat besser die weiße
kutte auszuziehen da stimme ich ihnen zu
was die staatlichen gutachten angeht
wenn sie das münchner gutachten mal
lesen und es ist ja öffentlich dann
haben sie nicht den eindruck dass hier
die kirche geschont werden soll also ich
würde schon sagen dass dieses münchner
gutachten doch sehr unabhängig ist auch
wenn die kirche der auftraggeber ist und
das ist auch schonungslos ist aber man
könnte vielleicht ansetzen und sagen
jetzt hat die kirche diese gutachten
alle bezahlt aber der staat könnte er
zumindest hingehen und die konsequenzen
überwachen also wenn er schon die chance
verpasst hat einige dieser gutachten zu
finanzieren und damit denen echte
unabhängigkeit zu geben dann könnte der
staat ja jetzt schon sagen wir
kontrollieren eben mal und das würde
dann eben auch verhindern dass sie im
bistum köln es immer noch niemanden gibt
der die täter kontrolliert denn das
stand in dem gutachten das sie das tun
sollten
nächste anruferin kommt aus bautzen
kerstin staritz ist am telefon seien sie
gegrüßt vorstand
[Musik]
mit der zweitgrößte arbeitgeber in
deutschland das bedeutet natürlich dass
all die menschenkinder die darin
beruflich auch immer jetzt sind ihre
arbeit verlieren würden in dem moment wo
wir auf natürliche austreten weil das
eine grundvoraussetzung ist unter
anderem sehe ich ein bewusstes
staatsversagen das bewusst weggeschaut
juristisch weil natürlich dann die
ganzen sozialen infrastrukturen
zusammenbrechen würde wenn ich die
illusion aufrechterhalten wird dass die
kirche praktisch diesbezüglich in tegel
dankeschön frau stritt die frau keller
möchte ihnen antworten ja also ich
möchte da doch auch die kirchen mal
verteidigen das sind nicht nur
wirtschaftsclubs die auf ihren eigenen
erhalt schielen
es stimmt das kirchliche arbeitsrecht
das muss sicherlich auch reformiert
werden
aber die die viele menschen finden auch
immer noch eine heimat in der in der
kirche und in den kirchengemeinden und
gemeinschaft in vielen landstrichen ist
die kirche mittlerweile der einzige ort
wo gemeinschaft noch stattfinden kann
wenn die dorfkneipe zu ist und es auch
sonst keine möglichkeiten mehr gibt und
ja ich möchte doch auch noch mal daran
erinnern dass es für manche menschen
auch oder für viele menschen auch
wichtig ist dass dann noch eine
institution ist die daran erinnert dass
es noch etwas anderes gibt dass dieses
leben hier auf erden vielleicht nicht
das einzige ist und die davor warnt dass
wir uns im paradies hier auf erden
schaffen können also die auch immer
wieder daran erinnern tut vielleicht ihr
menschen könnt nicht alles ihr habt auch
nicht die wahrheit und
vielleicht solltet ihr auch nicht alles
tun was ihr könnt also so eine instanz
ist für viele doch auch noch sehr
wichtig aber umso umso dramatischer
finde ich wenn dann das top personal
also deutschlands top seelsorger die
bischöfe eben in dieser seelsorge
versagen und nicht bei den betroffenen
sind und häufig von den normalen
gläubigen sehr weit entfernt sind weil
die vertun eben die chance vorbilder zu
sein für diese geistige heimat die
natürliche laichen die glaubwürdigkeit
so dass dann auch in den anderen
aussagen mehr geglaubt wird ja das ist
wirklich dramatisch um kirchen und zum
arbeitsrecht hat charlotte luftsack aus
aachen eine frage frau lübzer ja bitte
schön
heute fragen welche chance es gibt das
kirchliche arbeitsrecht abzuschaffen so
dass es in deutschland nun auch das
staatliche arbeitsrecht gibt hintergrund
ist dass ich mit 18 aus der katholischen
kirche ausgetreten bin und um dann
später im leben in aachen im sozialen
bereich arbeiten zu können musste ich in
die kirche wieder eintreten weil hier
die kirchlichen arbeitgeber sehr sehr
dominant sind und ich bin dann mal
letzten arbeit auch wieder aufgetreten
also gibt es eine chance das kirchliche
arbeitsrecht abzuschaffen die frage ist
ein typ mann danke frau lück die chance
sehe ich nicht weil es gibt aus guten
gründen ja ein tendenz schutz ja also
auch bei anderen organisationen wie
politischen parteien
und es muss schon zu den freiheiten der
religionsgemeinschaften gehören dass man
die inneren angelegenheiten selbst
regelt also die eigene glaubenslehre und
dass die menschen die für die kirche
stehen als ihre beschäftigten also
zumindest in einklang zu bringen sind
mit dem wofür die kirche ideell steht im
grundsatz es muss natürlich
differenzierungen geben je nach art der
tätigkeit also eine reinigungskraft in
einem kirchlichen haus muss jetzt nicht
sozusagen dieselbe linientreue in
anführungsstrichen haben wir jetzt ein
mensch der in der verkündigung tätig ist
also es haben ja jetzt auch einige
bischöfe nach dieser doku wie gott und
schuf angekündigt dass sie also etwa bei
der sexualmoral dann auch abstriche
machen wollen und dass jeder willkommen
ist also es tut sich was aber wir werden
sicher nicht dahin kommen dass man sagt
da gilt einfach nur staatliches
arbeitsrecht und die übereinstimmung mit
dem was kirche vertritt
moralisch oder im glauben religiös
spielt keine rolle mehr ist es nun ist
es ja so dass gerade im sozialbereich
ein großteil
der institution die die katholische
kirche unterhält staatlich lennons wert
oder überwiegend finanziert sind was
viele gar nicht vermuten r logisch ist
es dann nicht doch ein punkt an dem man
sagen muss kirchliches arbeitsrecht in
der weise hat keine zukunft kann sich
der staat daraus ziehen und sagen na
bisher ist es halt so das was herr
püttmann argumentiert das ist auch die
argumentation des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und die halten
denen einfach immer die stange aber
natürlich ist das reformierbar und dass
man in einem bewerbungsgespräch erzählen
muss ob meiner kirche ist oder nicht und
die man eigentlich lebt das sollte
fallen und das sollte das feld nur unter
druck die kirche ich habe ja gesagt ist
eine schnecke und auch die veränderung
der grundordnung also der
vorzeichen unter denen gearbeitet wird
die wird ewig dauern wenn der druck eben
nicht anhält er steigt ja also weil mir
jetzt kirchliche gerichte flow
beobachten wenn wir jetzt kirchliche
gerichte beobachten dann fangen die das
immer wieder ein also immer wieder gibt
es menschen die eben klagen gegen eine
kündigung weil sie zum beispiel
geschieden sind und wieder verheiratet
sind und wo früher ein deutsches gericht
gar nicht mehr ran gar nicht angegangen
wäre gibt es jetzt eben entscheide dass
der chefarzt einer düsseldorfer klinik
einer katholischen zum beispiel weiter
arbeiten darf und da sagen experten
schon dass das das sozusagen die
weltlichen gerichten dieses kirchliche
arbeitsrecht die akzente einschränken
werden
die nächste anruferin ist marlies der
aus mering rufen sie an frau dr sie sind
dran ich habe ihn eine frage
vielleicht dass ich die katholische
eigentlich geplant in ihrer reaktion
denn zb peter gegen das zölibat
verstoßen haben weil so nicht wirklich
jemanden geschädigt haben und dem
missbrauch an kindern und deren
verbrechen und die auch dann noch in der
ganzen leben darunter leiden danke frau
dr wer möchte doppelmoral der kirche ja
es ist sicher ein kernproblem dass diese
missbrauchstaten nur zu lange nur unter
dem gesichtspunkt zölibats bruch
behandelt wurden also
vom verhältnis des täters zu seiner
institution her gesehen
und dass dadurch der eindruck entstehen
konnte das eigentlich schlimme ist der
zölibat bruch und nicht dem missbrauch
staat aber ich meine doch das also
inzwischen vielleicht nicht
flächendeckend aber doch auch die
erkenntnis einzug gehalten hat das ist
nicht so sein kann dass es hier
entscheidend darauf ankommen wie loyal
ist der priester gegenüber seinem
versprechen gewesen den zölibat zu
halten sondern wie ist die menschenwürde
verletzt worden dass das das eigentliche
verbrechen ist das einfach ausbrechen
was noch fehlt ist also die anpassung
des kirchlichen rechts etwa dass das
recht auf sexuelle selbstbestimmung
zum beispiel auch ins kirchenrecht
aufgenommen wird und dass man sozusagen
aus den etwas antiquierten rechtsnormen
die alle vom sechste gebot herkamen
herauskommt und sich etwas modernisiert
aber ich glaube die frage ging auch in
die richtung dass ein priester der in
frankreich war es eben mit einer frau
zusammen war das der ganz klar
zurücktreten muss und dass ein priester
der eben kinder geschädigt hat nicht
zurücktreten muss und da kann ich mehr
sagen wirklich ehrlich sagt auch die
zellen davor dass ich davor zu machen
möchten noch kurzvorträge und das geht
an sie auch als letzte frage weiß auch
im letzen rolle spielt und weil ich
finde wir haben etwas unter beleuchtet
das ist die rolle der frauen in der
katholischen kirche wenn man in die
gemeindearbeit guckt vor ort spielen
frauen eine riesige rolle wenn man aber
guckt wo sind die machtvollen positionen
dann werden die in der katholische
kirche nach wie vor fehlen für die
männer reserviert das spielt auch im
letzten rolle wo leute sich beschweren
und sagen das muss sich doch ändern das
kann doch so nicht mehr sein wird sich
da was tun ich glaube da sind wir an dem
punkt an dem wir schon oft waren es wenn
es sich nicht ändert werden noch mehr
menschen gehen dann kann man einerseits
sagen ja aber katholische kirche ist
eine weltkirche und die wird weiter
existieren
aber ich glaube dass die deutsche
katholische kirche sich entscheidend
verändern wird wenn sich jetzt nicht
wenn das sich nicht öffnet und wenn die
frauen nicht die position kriegen die
sie eben gewohnt sind und diese für ihr
engagement eben auch verdienen
der löwe schmidt keine eindeutig also
ich finde dass bei diesen ganzen das ist
ja eine das ist ja schrecklich und trist
manchmal über das thema kirche und diese
katholische katastrophe zu berichten
aber eines ist schon
wirklich bewegend und nötigt einem
respekt und bewunderung ab nämlich die
frauen die kämpfen nicht nur von maria
20 sondern auch durchaus in
herausgehobenen positionen wie zum
beispiel die neue caritas-präsident in
die einfach kein blatt vor den mund
nimmt und die auch sagt wir müssen am
arbeitsrecht was machen ja also es ist
da es eine kraft da und sagen keine
erneuerung ohne dass auch die rolle der
frauen in der katholischen kirche neu
definiert wird eindeutig da wird genügt
bei in ihrem tisch dankeschön das war
nämlich der presseclub nachgefragt auf
phoenix einen schönen sonntag aus köln
wünschen wir ihnen machen sie es gut
genießen sie den sonnenschein den es
heute in teilen deutschlands auch gibt
und hoffentlich bis zum nächsten mal und
ich sage danke mich noch mal bei meinen
gästen
[Musik]